foreign
let's go to Janelle in Phoenix what's up
Janelle
hello how's it going
it's going fairly well awesome how can I
help what's up
well I'm calling because I've got a
interesting Dynamic occurring that I
could use a little bit of health and
insight with awesome
um I went through a very difficult
divorce about five years ago I had been
married for 15 years
and the last three years of that
marriage was pretty difficult with
emotional and
um
just verbal abuse
but when I finally made the decision and
had the strength to leave that marriage
I was completely at peace I had no
animosity or bitterness towards him
whatsoever I just wanted better for
myself and I knew that I'd done
everything you know that I could do to
make our marriage work I left no stone
unturned at the end of the day I just
didn't have a willing participant in
that marriage with me
um I had prepared myself and planned for
the fact that he would never completely
be out of my life due to the fact that
we share two children together
but what I could not have anticipated or
prepared myself for was how he would
continue to be a part of my life through
the close associations that he maintains
with many of my close family members
she's kidding me
I wish I was why
um
well
I don't it's it's really complicated
there's just so much to it um can I be
honest it's usually not I mean usually
there's a lot of like spinning things
and firecrackers and money is it money
does he have a lot of money
um he does yes yeah so um I do not we
split um it was a very inequitable
divorce it drove on over
two years and I finally just had to kind
of throw up my hands and walk away
because
um the peace that I left the marriage
with was leaving me and I was really
starting
to have bitterness and hatred towards
the father of my children and I just did
not want to feel that way about him okay
can we can I stop you right there can we
let's let's go back you hear me say this
a lot but in in on in an effort to
choose reality let's frame this in the
right way okay
okay you traded you sold
your stake in the financial claim
for peace
okay five years later three years later
you can be annoyed at yourself or
frustrated that you made that trade but
I wouldn't call it inequitable it's one
that you made
okay this the second thing is
is
hatred is strong
but if the father of your kids is a
scumbag the father of your kids is a
scumbag
and if he's going to try to take the why
the mother of his kids to the cleaners
in order to leave her with nothing
that's not a person I want to be around
I've got some friends who've been
through divorce that treated each other
with such dignity and respect I laugh at
them and said man where was that when
you are married right trying to burn
down the mother of your kids
is one of the least Noble things I can
think of
and so if he's a scumbag he's a scumbag
often I hear women who've been divorced
they they struggle with saying that
somebody's a scumbag because they think
it reflects back on you
why did I have a family with this guy
why did I stick around so long why did I
choose this person do you have anything
like that
foreign and I don't disagree that he I
mean he he in my eyes he is a scumbag
and I think that's why it's so difficult
for me to
make peace with the relationships that
he continues to have with my family
members have you told your family
members explicitly this makes me
uncomfortable
yeah I've told them that it feels very
dismissive of
um the pain and
that he's caused to me and the abuse
that I experienced it at hand
um because he's very financially
generous with them Ah that's even that
makes it worse man that means they like
to ride they like the ride
I know and so I
if I had my dream I would
I would they would say you know what
that's very generous of you to offer to
me but I can't in good conscience accept
that gift from you knowing how
how ungenerous you have been is that a
word did I just make words how
um the lack of generosity that you have
you know you failed to be generous or
fulfill your obligations to your former
spouse and therefore your children
um oh Janelle Janelle do you know how
many times have you played that fantasy
out in your mind
maybe three or four times I don't know
yeah right three or four thousand
the
okay I'm I I
just feel this sense I'm gonna be super
honest with you what I'm gonna say is
gonna be really hard is that cool
yep your family has chosen him over you
and I hate that for you
I do too
this isn't about him and this isn't
about your family this is about you
listening to this conversation the
person I'm most mad at
the person I'm having the most
difficulty with is your family
not him I don't get mad at a rattlesnake
for being a rattlesnake I walk away I
don't interact with rattlesnakes
dude this is your family
and they've been my best friends and
that's where
they haven't yeah
yeah all right let me let me tell you
we're best friends this is how
one of my closest friends in the world
is named John and his wife is named
Jennifer and she's ride or die
she called me one time on my phone this
is years ago she said I just met
so-and-so who says they know you
here's what she followed up with are we
friends with her or not
and I said yes and she goes cool
she was saying we ride or die
are we letting somebody else in this
little group because if not cool I'm
moving on with my life
that's how best friends roll
best friends don't
see what you're gonna give them
and then as soon as you turn your back
turn to the person who hurt their
their child their sister their brother
and say hey can you make my life a
little shinier
oh man you got parsed out for 20 pieces
of silver dude it breaks my heart for
you
yeah
mine too that's like as if divorce isn't
hard enough you know and just grieving
all of that that comes with that and
then to feel like
like it's just forever altered the
Dynamics of my relationships with my
sister my best friend because two of her
children are employed by my ex
um another one of her another one of her
children
um is going through a lot of help she
and her husband are going through a lot
of health challenges and my ex has made
several donations
to them to help them which you know and
on the other hand Dr John I'm so
grateful right because he's helping my
nieces and my nephews and
getting them out of some sticky
situations but it's just so gross and it
feels calculated by him too as another
way to kind of control and manipulate
and rub in my face
um what if you what if you
completely unplugged from him
and this is me completely this is me
completely changing tracks let me say
this I'm completely changing what I said
earlier okay
so the story as it goes I feel like your
family has chosen him he's got money
he's got resources and they're gonna
they've gone that way
but what if
you just went to thirty thousand feet
and he can make all the calculations he
wants
but you're not you're not even in the
math class anymore
and he can donate money and help people
with their medical bills good on him
but I'm not going to give him another
second
and it might feel gross to you but your
friend's getting her her cancer
treatment or whatever so good good on
them
and when you show up if he happens to be
invited to a thing I'm gonna go
and your friends could know if you if
you choose to invite him over your
choosing for me to not be here that's
fair
I'll just go
but I think the soul tax you're
expending on this dude
it's killing you right
yes it is and that's what
emotional
real estate
you know and mental real estate in my
life and in my brain and I just don't
know how to
but at the same time the peop my normal
confidants
are I feel like I'm losing them you are
yeah
and the fact that you haven't forgiven
him yet
is drowning you not him
yeah I know
you got to let him go man
I know you're still mad about what
happened huh
well yeah and I just I think I'm so
frustrated because I can't even explain
how at peace I was
when we finally separated I just
couldn't
imagine
all the muck he would drag me through in
the divorce and
um you know when I left I had collected
I'd stayed home with our boys for 10
years and I had collected two paychecks
from my new job when I moved out and
moved in with my parents and I'm still
there five years later with my parents
meanwhile he's bought another business
and he's purchased a million dollar home
and
I I know that it's not healthy for me to
dwell on those things you know this is
jealousy Let It Go yeah yeah it's
poisoning you
and you've heard that a million times
but
you're drinking poison hope he dies
hoping he dies
and there's something to be said for
applauding the fact that your kids are
going to be able to go to college
because their dad's a millionaire
but five years later you're at your
parents house because you still are
choosing to be at your parents house
true or false
um I I'm priced out of the market I
could not afford to I just went back to
school finished
my degree uh second degree and I
currently working towards being able to
afford movie now yes okay
the jealousy five years and the
frustration and the poison are not worth
it he's still running your life and he's
not even there
well he is
but yeah he's there more than just that
too and that's what I'm I'm wanting to
let go but it feels like I've got to let
go of
relationships in my family too which is
hard and another thing to be bitter
about right and I don't want to be it's
just
where I am but I want I I want to be
free of that whenever somebody hurts us
whenever somebody
violates our our
relationship
bitterness feels like we get regained
some sort of control over them
bitterness feels good sometimes
we don't talk about that enough but
being pissed off feels good
and the only problem with it is it
doesn't work
it doesn't change them or alter them
most of the time they don't even know
just destroys us
so you've heard me say this a thousand
times and I'll wind up saying a thousand
times more I would love for you
to go to
um
a local Home Depot and pick up a couple
of cinder blocks and put some duct tape
on them or put some masking tape on them
and write down
in the black marker on that masking tape
this man abused me and he hurt me
and he dragged me through the mud
and
he wasn't just this man he was your best
friend he was your husband he's the dad
of your kids you had plans with this guy
it was your life
and I want you to carry that cinder
block around until it gets so heavy your
hands are exhausted your shoulders are
exhausted then once you go to the
backyard in your parents house and throw
that sucker down let it sit but
consciously say I'm no longer carrying
him
and I want you to tear off that piece of
tape and wad it up and throw it away and
Mark that day is the day I decided to
stop carrying him and then over the next
couple of months when something pops up
something pops up something pops up that
thought that anger that frustration that
jealousy
you can say to yourself not carrying
that anymore and your body will have
a moment you'll have stuck a flag in the
ground it says this is the day that I
quit carrying this
and this is the day I decided to start
building something new you haven't
started building something new you're
still just sitting in the ash of what
was so pissed
is that fair yeah it's fair
and you may have to do that that same
thing with another cinder block about
your sister
yeah and your best friend and and and
and
uh
I'm sorry
and there is a gratitude side to this
that he's a dad that still shows up to
kids stuff
and you got to grit your teeth and smile
and
you all both have to be adults for your
kids you can do that you can do hard
things like that
you can too
what you're gonna find is when he
realizes he has lost his grasp over you
the dynamic will change
I promise it will change
but until then you can practice it
and let's make a plan to get our two our
two feet underneath us
let's make a in eight months I'm moving
out of my parents house
even if it's into a small apartment
in 12 months I'm filling the blank in 16
months I'm let's begin to build
something new
and not just make snow angels in the ash
of what was because our lives are so
quick they're so short
to just waste them being bitter and
angry
even when God I'm so bitter and angry
angry you're worth so much more Janelle
so much more
hang on the line I'm gonna send you a
copy of my best-selling book own your
past change your future I want you to go
through that and it will give you a road
map out